today is uh day 18. just finished day 18
of the 90 day challenge i'm 20
through my challenge
how am i doing hard to tell some days i
feel i'm not making any progress i think
i am i think i understand more
uh tomorrow not tomorrow monday i have a
discussion with
with
a person that i spoke to in korean many
many months ago we'll see if she thinks
that i've made any progress of course i
will make progress
i know that from experience you just
have to keep at it even when you think
you aren't making progress
and today for example i had various
errands to run had to wait in an office
for an hour
so i felt that i would have trouble
getting in my um
my learning but i did a couple of
articles when i say i did i linked i
went through creating links for a couple
of articles from uh
chosen ilbo in the morning listened
while clearing the uh
breakfast dishes and
cleaning things and stuff like that
i had probably 45 minutes of doing flash
cards while waiting in this office
uh probably another
i would say half an hour to 40 minutes
in the car
listening
uh
then i discovered some very good
articles
in our library at link
which uh what are they called again here
it's part of a collection contributed by
imani who's our great benefactor
and it is cbs kyogen use
and lots of good articles there with
audio and text so i went through and i
linked about three or four of those
which i'm going to be reading
on my handy ipad before i go to bed i'll
knock off those articles so one way or
another i'll think i i think i will get
my two and a half or so hours in today
it's important to stay with it because
it's it's relentless you have to it's
just a process of attrition you're
beating down this language creating
habits and so we just have to stay with
it and and uh ordinarily i probably
wouldn't have done anything today but
because i have this 90-day challenge i
feel
obligated to force myself that's what
the whole challenge is about and uh so
and of course if you've been following
the challenge or if you're participating
if you get the
updates you'll see just how many people
are participating which languages are
the most popular
uh english is i think number one and
then french spanish russian german are
in there
um so it's going well and i hope
everyone else is enjoying it i am
even though i don't feel i've made any
tremendous strides i kind of brought
myself back to where i was
one interesting thing
uh reading in a different alphabet so
reading in hangul is always a strain
i always found reading in the russian
alphabet a strain because ever since i
was started reading i've been reading in
the
roman or the latin alphabet
but now after reading my korean uh i was
just reading some stuff on our
russian language forum at link that was
in russian of course and it's easier to
read now you know it's a bit like like
resistance training
by forcing myself to read so much korean
i find the russian a real delight to
read now less resistance to reading in
in that you know
uh reading in czech is is easier in a
way
because it's in the familiar alphabet
doesn't matter those are the joys of
learning another language one thing i
wanted to mention too is
you know i one of the things i did today
by the way uh again while listening to
some extent until i just got tired of
listening i was cleaning up my books
because i found uh in my uh
audio files there was the audio files
from a thing called
which is a japanese
uh
series for learning uh korean and they
have other languages that they teach as
well and it's particularly good and i
couldn't find the book anywhere so and i
buried amongst all my books so i was
looking all over and as i did that of
course i looked at all the different
books that i bought for korean over the
years when i particularly six whenever i
was seven eight years ago ago and i got
very keen on korean and one thing that
is very clear
is that the the books
for learning korean that are produced in
the united states or canada ubc for
example
uh are much inferior to the books that
you can get in japan
remarkably inferior and the reason is
because
in these books like these
and these
and these which is a humongous series
you've got a ratio of actual language
content
to
superfluous explanation and exercises
and drills like the content is less than
10
of a book like this there's hardly any
content in it
lots of explanations where they try to
account for every possible variation of
the language it seems to me
you know things that we'll eventually
get used to once we have enough words
you know the language all languages are
somewhat redundant we'll figure out what
they're trying to say
we don't need it we don't need all that
what we need is interesting content and
the other problem with the books that
are produced in north america other than
the one at ubc my favorite
uh north american book is that the
content is so dreadfully boring
eight out of ten
in intermediate in beginner it's all
about these quaint aspects of korean
culture which are not that interesting
i had to say when i was learning
japanese i'm not that interested in
german in the japanese festivals you
know shigosan or whatever
in my daily life in japan i had very
little reason to be interested in those
what's interesting is the daily life of
people in different situations or in my
case history and and
current events and so forth but even
people in different situations uh going
to parties having fun but genuine and so
then you get to japan and that's what
they give you they have uh this
dekirokan
this one here was not so good this was
kanyo hyogen i i you know often with
these books
you get to them later on at the present
time i'm not that fond of this the
lessons are too short but the the
intermediate level dekiru kankuko is
excellent i can't find the book here i
may have to order it again i was hoping
i could find a electronic version on the
internet so that i could import it into
link but then notice all these notice
the size of the japanese books
versus the
you know north american books
you know
huge
and not to mention the the price of them
like 20 or 25
and mostly just content content now
granted i may have made there may be
other books that i didn't buy but you
know uh kbs excellent quality
uh sound quality is excellent content is
excellent uh i can't really
follow these all that well but i will
i'm gonna get to these again
uh i failed in my attempt to try and
scan these so that i can read them on
link it doesn't seem to work scanning is
not accurate enough
uh but the japanese books like these
those books that i showed you the other
day with the patterns limited amount of
explanation here's the language and
listen to it repeat it here's what these
words mean
very practical
uh so i don't know why that is i think
it's probably the influence of
linguistics and i don't know
sociolinguistics and and the you know
the north because it's it's handled more
by the the universities in north america
and they're hoping to be peer-reviewed
and get their books approved by
different academic you know departments
whereas in japan
people are competing to produce books
that people will actually buy and enjoy
and find useful and and tell their
friends to buy so it's a whole different
you know business model and i think the
commercial business model that operates
in japan for these language books it
results in better books at any rate 20
through my challenge
now going off to do a bit more a reading
on my ipad having
sort of slogged my way through them
linking the words that i didn't know